[تصفيق]
[موسيقى] أجنبية
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أنه سيكون هناك دائمًا مكان
للمسارح ، أعني أن هذه ليست
المرة الأولى التي تتعرض فيها الأفلام للتهديد أو يتعرض التلفزيون
للتهديد ولكننا سنعود دائمًا
لأن هناك
حتى بالنسبة لي شيء مميز جدًا بشأن تصوير
فيلم مع أشخاص آخرين من حولك ، أو
تسمع الضحك أو ترى أشخاصًا
يسحبون مناديلهم ، إنها
تجربة ، نعم ، إنها
تجربة يريدون دور العرض أولاً
لأن الجميع أكبر ،
إنها تجربة  حدث أكبر ويريدون
إعادة الأفلام التي تعرف أن
هوليوود تزدهر على أن كل واحد من
هؤلاء المخرجين الذين لن يسمحوا
بمشاهدة فيلمهم في أي مكان إلا في
المسرح وأنا إلى جانبهم نوعًا ما.
يشاهدون في المنزل وهم
يشاهدون على أجهزة الكمبيوتر الخاصة بهم في بعض الأحيان ،
إنه عالم جديد وعلينا جميعًا
التكيف معه [
تصفيق]
شكرًا لك [
موسيقى]
أجنبية
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أن هناك
انتظارًا  لمفاجأتنا ،
سنعتاد على الطريقة التي اعتدنا بها على
أشياء كثيرة
وأصبحت جزءًا من حياتنا وكان هناك
حديث كافٍ عن سعر
تجربة الفيلم ، لذلك أعتقد أن هناك
تغييرًا هائلاً كما
حدث  كنا في كل جانب من جوانب حياتنا ،
والآن نرى أنها تتحرك بشكل أسرع ، لذا
يصعب تخمينها ، لذا فإن الأشخاص الذين
يمكنهم التكيف والأشخاص الذين يمكنهم عرض
هؤلاء سيكونون الفائزين
[موسيقى]
هوليوود أجنبية
[تصفيق]